oh [ __ ]
it's the [ __ ] Lord's Day you
dare enter this house
it's the [ __ ] house of pain on
the Lord's Day but the beautiful thing
about this is that you're here and just
like that the clouds part and show you
the beauty of the skies uncle Joey here
Sunday September 10th let me tell you
something floral to my heart goes out to
you and all the remaining [ __ ] areas
around there God knows whatever miss
thinking the limitation I know where
you're [ __ ] thinking you're thinking
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here I'm
gonna chill for a couple days smoke some
dope maybe do a few bumps have some
cocktails and once the storm goes down
I'll come back and I'll salvage whatever
is left because you know what your house
ain't worth your life get the [ __ ] out
of there just in case the power is gonna
go out to cats gonna [ __ ] abandon
ship and they know better one of those
gyms or all those Florida people fart
and [ __ ] but they your life is worth two
[ __ ] million pictures you follow me I
don't even know what that means but it
really doesn't matter cuz it's uncle
joey's day here on the Lord's Day
periscope get your [ __ ] together I got
some [ __ ] that Roz dude gave me last
night I smoked it when I got home I
passed out I had to have a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich at 2:30 in the
morning in this you know it's like to
pass out then wake up in the middle of
night [ __ ] starving thinking you're
in a desert that's how strong this
reefer is he gave me two [ __ ]
different containers one is debt and the
other ones is cousin coma [ __ ] it that's
what we're doing today on a Sunday
[ __ ] morning don't forget tonight
podcasts six seven o'clock hot time
whenever we get there just get ready to
rock on a Monday morning but joy which
with the chitter chatter
spark that [ __ ] number up you
understand me
for you [ __ ] down south I will
be at the Cherokee Casino in Oklahoma
next Saturday with Kate Quigley one show
and no [ __ ] drama if you get on the
roller skates right now you'll be there
by Saturday beside that it's another
week last week was last week you had a
couple humps and bumps shits
crack-a-lackin' [ __ ] it you don't give a
[ __ ] this week you're coming out to jump
like [ __ ] you know a man possessed
like Cosby beaten let out of jail with a
box of quaaludes up to twenty years what
would you be thinking like that's how
you gotta think I'm coming on I'm [ __ ]
tearing people apart you understand me
because it's that time of the year stir
for thought you ain't got time to [ __ ]
around with joy
what's with the chitter chatter drop
some [ __ ] reefer smoke on me
absolutely the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy [ __ ] ghost there you
go
my balsam smoke towards [ __ ] Florida
and push that [ __ ] hurricane back
down on the [ __ ] and whatever the [ __ ] I
also want to give a shout-out to my
relatives in Cuba pick up the [ __ ]
phone I know the phone line picked up
it's like 1920 down there they still
gotta call the operator all that man
don't sit oh no what the [ __ ] just dial
the right [ __ ] beside that let's smoke
another no I mean what are we here for
the [ __ ] chit chat and talk if I
wanted to talk to somebody I got on the
Starbucks and listened to the economic
sanctions of political get the [ __ ] out
of here just get your [ __ ] together to
stop with this company everybody wants
to be a genius but nobody knows what the
[ __ ] Hurricanes gonna end up even
though there's that Tuesday it was here
Thursday with Chicago but these are
[ __ ] in everybody's a [ __ ] genius
I tell you why cuz it's a hypothesis
it's an educated guess eight white dudes
get together or what do you think that
the [ __ ] out here take a chance Columbus
did give him that car and had [ __ ]
north [ __ ]
back to reefer and bring a Jamaican
widget
oh it's nothing better than getting
together with you savages on a Sunday
morning to plot out our [ __ ]
following we can get it on and do this
nobody has these up until he's like us
you know why Cruz will [ __ ] it on me
Molly that's why because we don't give a
[ __ ] we're looking at next week like a
[ __ ] appetizer that's the way I look
at the weeks now Monday through Fridays
an appetizer I ain't got time to [ __ ]
around you follow me every morning you
wake up and you justify your existence
and then you can't sit there at the end
of the angle I don't know what's
happening my luck is running out now you
never created your own but you've been
sitting there waiting for the [ __ ]
somebody I'm not gonna do and give you a
[ __ ] dollar bill I ain't gonna work
that way you gotta get up you gotta get
up you gotta write your goals you have
to do your push-ups a guy tell everybody
you suck your dick during that time for
parties and get-togethers I get these
people that some of these things every
weekend we'll have a get-together club
mink on Hollywood listen you got a
better chance to get raped by ten
[ __ ] brothers putting that big black
boots on your muffler than me showing up
I got [ __ ] they're doing people see I'm
gonna sit around ha ha you got out you
you could always be doing something you
could always be doing something I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody tells you
there's always something it them and
worst case scenario you can do what I do
and your boys smoke reefer smoke free
from write something stupid and there
you don't but at least you're doing
something you're not clear you're not
thick you know what's that [ __ ] I
don't I don't han just a devil's [ __ ]
playground because you're sitting and
all these stupid thoughts are going into
your [ __ ] mind
you gotta bark that [ __ ] when you're
jumping up and down when you're hustling
that's what good shit's happening but
you got a ticket to [ __ ]
Wieland emotion ain't gonna happen by
itself you know Sam excuse me while I
take a hit of this [ __ ] death here
[Applause]
you know it's good when it's done in the
morning you hear in Chinese people
yelling that's always a good sign of the
day ahead footballs on I know you
[ __ ] got your picks you ready
to [ __ ] go good luck
but listen before you start the season
and lose money and win money and get
into a hole you never seen a bookie with
a part-time job take that money put in a
[ __ ] hole and take the other half and
smoke some reefer you'll get more
[ __ ] satisfaction that's what I did
when I was listen I used to gamble and
lose every week what would you rather do
lose and gap won't give you money to a
bookie or look out a window and do blow
Hey I chose B look how the window and
blue do blow man they give my money
there's some [ __ ] bookie suck my dick
we'll call me shorty
uncle Joey was born in 1940 you don't
think anyone would somebody spend some
time with the family and then I had a
podcast tonight Evie you in oh yeah
that's the new [ __ ] model here around
the church yeah he can't be in halfway
in between him Sam
just please you're not the game don't
mean you don't have the uniform on you
always got a uniform on you always ready
to stab the [ __ ] how to order
and beside that you know I love your
[ __ ] I want to give a shout-out
to my niece over there Philadelphia
kicking cancers ass Lindsey runny I'm
gonna go out there and visit her and I'm
gonna go to [ __ ] Pittsburgh I love
you Lindsey hang in there you [ __ ]
Savage I also wanna give a shout out to
my man Bob Lowe Lingus sending me a
Black Sabbath book I wanna give a shout
out to my boys out of Secaucus running
things
Timmy Holloway and little Ryan all the
way and Julia you know you know we do
with your dog I got a [ __ ] lookout I
throw you [ __ ] and beside that
I'm like it stopped that's it you know
yeah I know hobbies huh I got a hobby I
collect Stachel stick on a pure [ __ ]
because of my happiest moments and
[ __ ] reefer
with the church friend that's it that's
not this Saturday
Cherokee [ __ ] Springs to see them
Oklahoma two weeks to Pittsburgh
improbable come in and have the
understand man I want ain't no [ __ ]
stories beside that I love you got goes
to right he got push-ups to do and you
have to be looking for something listen
when you're leaving the house right now
you think it is so somebody's gonna
sniff my ballsack today oh it's not
gonna be a perfect [ __ ] day and even
if that also meant big ball sack at
least you went out with it in mind if
they keep calling out with it eventually
somebody's gonna comp enjoy but I sniff
your ball sacks that's the way it
happens besides that I love your
[ __ ] Tampa Sarasota all the
surrounding areas I got your back you
[ __ ] hold on to dear life hold
on to a pole
wrap yourself like a [ __ ] put a rope
around that I don't give a [ __ ] what you
need to do I got you I love you I'll be
thinking about you or in Miami that you
think I'm I might tell our pain that
side well I've been through a lot
today's your lucky day [ __ ]
if you get something bad cuz remember
there's a silver lining and everything
there's a silver lining and everything
I'm here to take a look at his face I
can beat up only thousand times and
there's a silver lining and everything
alright have a great day with your
family stayed tough don't take no [ __ ]
from nobody and tell them all to suck it
dick they think I might tell our bean
yeah I've seen you [ __ ] tonight
seven o'clock
be there or go [ __ ] yourself